السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
الله اكبر الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر اشهد ان لا اله الا الله
الله اشهد ان
لا اله
الا
الله اشهد ان
ان
محمدا رسول
الله اشهد
ان
محمدا رسول الله
حي على
الصلاه حي على الصلاه
[Silence]
حي على الفلاح
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
لا اله
الا الله ا
[Silence]
ان الحمد
لله نحمده ونستعينه
ونستغفره ونعوذ بالله من شرور
انفسنا ومن سيئات
اعمالنا من يهده الله فلا مضل له ومن يضلل
فلا هادي له واشهد ان لا اله الا الله
وحده لا شريك له واشهد ان محمدا عبده
ورسوله صلى الله عليه وعلى اله واصحابه
وسلم تسليما
كثيرا يا ايها الناس اتقوا ربكم الذي
خلقكم من نفس واحده وخلق منها زوجها وبث
منهما رجالا كثيرا
ونساء واتقوا الله الذي تساءلون به
والارحام ان الله كان عليكم
رقيبا يا ايها الذين امنوا اتقوا الله
وقولوا قولا
سديدا يصلح لكم
اعمالكم ويغفر لكم ذنوبكم ومن يطع الله
ورسوله فقد فاز فوزا
عظيما يا ايها الذين امنوا اتقوا الله حق
تقاته حق تقاته ولا تموتن الا وانتم
مسلمون الله
اكبر الله اكبر الله
اكبر لا اله الا
الله الله اكبر الله اكبر ولله
الحمد حلم على جنبات الشام ام عيد لا الهم
هم ولا التسهيد تسهيد
اتكب العين والرايات
خافقه ام تكذب الاذن والدنيا
اغاريد الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر لا
اله الا
الله الله اكبر الله اكبر ولله
الحمد اللهم لك الحمد اور برز ان سيريا
‏no
الحمد
الله
الله he them
الحمد
لله
الله الحمد
لله الحمد
لله اسقط الاسد وتطهرت بالريسه البلد
اسقطوا
هبل اسقطوا هبل واحيوا في الامه
الامل والنصر في سوريا بفضل الله اكتمل
فقطع دابر القوم الذين ظلموا والحمد لله
رب
العالمين
الله الحمد لله رب
الله يقول ابن عاشور في تفسير هذه
الايه يحق الحمد لله عند هلاك
الظلمه لان هلاكهم صلاح
للناس والصلاح اعظم
النعم وشكر
النعمه واجب فالحمد لله رب
العالمين ابن
عاشور تير ايه
[Silence]
الله
اللهج الحمد لله رب
العالمين لله الامر
كله لله الامر من قبل ومن بعد ويومئذ يفرح
المؤمنون وما النصر الا من عند
الله قل بفضل الله وبرحمته فبذلك فليفرحوا
هو خير مما يجمعون
[Silence]
الحمد ان شا
الله الله سبحانه وتالى
[Silence]
الحمد
لله الله سبحانه
وتالى الله سبحانه
وتعالى نحسبهم
حس الله سبحانه
وتالى يفرحون
الصحابه بنصر الروم على الفرس فمن باب
اولى ان نفرح بنصر اخواننا في سوريا
ولا لا يكون
علينا
الياس الياس من
الشيطان فلا يياس من روح
الله الا القوم الكافرون
‏we
hopeful سانه
وتالى الله سبحانه
[Silence]
وتالى الحمد
لله الله سبحانه
وتعالى لولا
دمشق لولا دمشق لما كانت
طليطله ولا زهت بني ولا زهت ببني العباس
بغدان امنت بالله واستثنيت جنته دمشق روح
وجنات
وريحان دمشق ديار
علمائنا دمشق
دمشق ابن
عساكر
الذهبي دمشق الذهبي وابن كثير
والمزي دمشق ابن مالك دمشق ابن
رجب ابن
القيم دمشق ديار امام الائمه وبحر الامه
حسنه الايام شيخ الاسلام ابن
تيميه يا اهل
الشام شكرا
لكم شكرا
لكم من كل
الامه على صبركم
وجهادكم
ورباط
وثباتكم رغم
الماسي
والالم رغم تكالب الامم ورغم صواريخه
واسلحتهم
والحمم ما ضعفت لهم يوما
الهمم وما هانوا وما وهنوا وما
استكانوا وكان يقينهم بالله ونصره
ثابت يس
[Silence]
شيطان الحمد لله الله
اكبر الله سبحانه
وتعالى الحمد لله رب
العالمين اللهم اغفر لنا ياسنا وضعف
ايماننا
بقدرتك
ومكرك يا اهل الشام
علمتمونا ان الحق لا يستجدى من
مغتصب لان ما اخذ اغتصابا لا يرد الا
غلابا
مبارك مبارك لكم يا اهل سوريا
اقول قولي هذا واستغفر الله لي ولكم
فاستغفروه انه هو الغفور والبر الرحيم
[Silence]
الحمد
لله الحمد لله رب
العالمين الحمد لله الذي يرحم العيون اذا
دمعت والقلوب اذا خشعت والنفوس اذا خضعت
والعزائم اذا
اجتمعت سبحانه الرؤوف اذا الاسباب
انقطعت المقصود اذا الناس امتنعت
اللطيف اذا صدمت الخطوب وصدعت فسبحان من
وسعت رحمته كل شيء وحق لها اذ وسعت احمده
سبحانه ذو صفات بهرت واشكره على نعم ظهرت
واشهد ان لا اله الا الله وحده لا شريك له
شهاده عن اليقين صدرت واشهد ان حبيبنا
ونبينا محمدا عبده ورسوله بعثه سبحانه
والفتنه قد قد
احتدت ويد الضلال قد
امتدت والحاجه قد اشتدت وظلمات الظلم قد
اسودت والجاهليه قد بلغت غايتها ووجبت
نهايتها فجاء سبحانه بمحمد صلى الله عليه
وسلم
فملك عانها وكبت اعيانها وظهرت اياته في
الجبابره فهلكت
فرسانها وفي قياصره وفي قيا وفي
قياصره
فنصت او
فصبت
صلبان وفي
الاكاسره فصدت
ايوانه ضح على
يده المحجه
وابان صلى الله عليه
وسلم سبحان
الله
نحمده فلقد ابانا بسنه نبيه صلى الله عليه
وسلم
الحق ونحسب اخواننا في
سوريا من اهل السنه فقد نصرهم الله سبحانه
وتعالى
كما
راينا من
مشاهد تدمع العيون وتكسر
القلوب من
جنود هذا
الحاكم لا يخافون الله
سبحانه ويضحكون
ويصورون نرى هذا
اليوم في فلسطين
كذلك
س الله سحانه وتعالى
[Silence]
الله سبحانه
وتعالى ان شاء الله
الحمد
لله ان شا
الله باذن الواحد
الاحد
of come
باذن
الله الله سبحانه
وتعالى
سست اللهم اعز الاسلام
والمسلمين واذل الشرك
والمشركين ودمر اعداءك اعداء الدين اللهم
ثبتنا على قولك الثابت في الحياه الدنيا
وفي الاخره
ربنا لا تزغ قلوبنا بعد اذ هديتنا وهب لنا
من لدنك رحمه انك انت الوهاب واصلح اللهم
احوالنا في الامور
كلها نسال
الله ان كما فرحنا بفرح
وبفرك في سوريا ان
يفرحنا
بفرجهم في فلسطين باذن الواحد الاحد انه
ولي ذلك والقادر عليه عباد الله ان الله
يامر بالعدل والاحسان وتاء ذي القربى
وينهى عن الفحشاء والمنكر والبغي يعظكم
لعلكم
تذكرون فاذكروا الله العلي القدير يذكركم
واشكروه على نعمه يزدكم ولذكر الله اكبر
والله يعلم ما تصنعون واقم الصلاه
الله اكبر الله اكبر اشهد ان لا اله الا
الله اشهد ان
محمدا رسول
الله حي على
الصلاه حي على
الفلاح قد قامت الصلاه قد قامت الصلاه
الله اكبر الله اكبر
لا اله الا
الله ان شاء الله
تكبيرات افترس باذن الله
استقيموا واعتدلوا تراصوا يرحمكم الله ولا
تختلفوا سد الخلل
ذاب الله اكبر
[Silence]
الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد
واياك
نستعين اهدنا
الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب
عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين اذا زلزلت الارض
زلزالها
واخرجت الارض
اثقالها وقال
الانسان
ماالها
يومئذ تحدث
اخبارها
بان ربك اوحى لها
يومئذ يصدر الناس
اشتاتا ليروا
اعمالهم فمن يعمل مثقال ذره
خيرا
يره
ومن يعمل مثقال
ذره
شرا
يره الله الله
[Silence]
اكبر سمع الله لمن حمده
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد
واياك
نستعين اهدنا
الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب
عليهم ولا
الضال
ين
امينين ارايت الذي يكذب
بالدين
فذلك الذي يدع اليتيم
ولا يحض على طعام
المسكين فويل
للمصلين الذين هم عن
صلاتهم
ساهون الذين هم
يراءون
ويمنعون الماعون
الله
[Silence]
اكبر سمع الله لمن حمده
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
السلام علكم رحمه
[Silence]
الله علكم
‏take
‏also the tait as you know are appr the
year not want the the year because we
have a need to use those f so as as you
a ch if you can donate
your st taes them and that to put
‏as and i have my
some
ch
some like
requ make
[Silence]
‏end beic as what you would
likey and like
make
yeares things
sping don
[Silence]
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر لا ال الا
الله الله الله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر
لا اله الا الله الله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
لا اله الا الله
الله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله الحمد الله اكبر
كبيرا والحمد لله
كثيرا وسبحان الله
وبحمده بكره وا صيلا لا اله الا الله وحده
صدق وعده ونصر عبده واعز جنده وهزم
الاحزاب وحده لا اله الا الله ولا نعبد
الا
اياه مخلصين له الدين ولو كره الكاف
الله اكبر
الله اكبر الله اكبر لا اله الا
الله
الله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر
الله اكبر الله اكبر
لا اله الا
الله الله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله
الحمد كمل
ولاك الله
[Silence]
السلام
عليكم ييك الله يخليك وطول عمرك
[Silence]
الله
ا
[Silence]
م
‏s
[Silence]
‏am
‏eh
[Silence]
جزاك
الله ما شاءء
الله بارك الله
والله
والحمد
لله
مليان
والجامع الحمد لله
[Silence]
ا
م
[Silence]
‏f
م
[Silence]
‏r
‏eh
[Silence]
عل
‏c
[Silence]
‏e
‏n
‏s
[Silence]
‏i
‏and
[Silence]
‏qu
‏p
‏all
[Silence]
‏ ‏
‏pass
[Silence]
‏med ان